this was Phil Cole seeing his daughter
Imogen after his latest round of cancer
treatment you okay
but on New Year's Eve Phil collapsed
with flu needing Urgent Care his wife
Sarah was told that their usual Cancer
Ward in central Birmingham was full that
the only bed available where he could
stay isolated was in here a makeshift
cubicle in the plaster room at their
local emergency department it was filthy
and there was an old bed in there which
the paramedics themselves had to make up
the bed had blood stains on the side of
it drips
um the sink was full of used bits and
Bobs the floor was filthy with stains
and tissue paper from previous patients
and I was really worried then because
he's so venerable and I was really
worried that he was going to pick up
something else and he was at risk of
more infection as well as the flu
while we were there
um which are voiced my concerns but this
staff were inundated and they're as
lovely again as the stuff where there's
nothing they could do
Warsaw Healthcare NHS trust says it
apologizes to the couple that at very
busy times like now things will
occasionally be overlooked but the
warning from the UK's doctors
Association is far more Stark in an open
letter to the Prime Minister the group
representing Frontline Medics says the
NHS is broken up to 500 people are dying
each week because of delays in emergency
NHS care
staff in hospitals and services across
the country have told us they simply
cannot cope we've spoken with a nurse
who works on one of the wards at this
hospital she's described the last three
weeks to us saying that they are simply
the toughest she has ever seen in her
career she says that staff are trying to
do a good job but it's simply not good
enough and that after every shift she's
had to sign an incident report saying
that things are unsafe
this trust told us that demand for their
services is very high that patient
safety is a top priority but there are
warnings that even the basics can't be
met pharmacists say shelves are emptying
of common cold and flu medicines due to
supply issues
this GP in Cheshire says they've never
seen a winter like it with so many calls
and GPS driving the sickest to hospital
because ambulances aren't coming
everybody you come to do this job
because you want to make a difference
you know you care and if you can't or if
you're trying to and you can see that
things aren't letting that happen and
you can see that there are people who
are going to go and become worse
you do you want to shout and say stop
stop what is going on why why is this
going on now
um and nobody's listening
the government today says it is
listening recruiting record numbers of
doctors and putting record levels of
funding into the service Catherine
evertots see Sky News